all right so who won the first round of
the draft i'm reluctant to do this
because
we're not going to know which of these
guys are good we're not going to know
which of these guys
aren't good half of them on average
aren't going to be good
those teams will have lost the draft we
won't know right away but knowing what
we know now seeing what we saw last
night
give me a team that you think won the
night uh
i would say that i think the chargers
won the night uh because they were able
to get a left tackle
a clear position of need and they were
able to get one of the best ones on the
board and rayshawn slater
i mean and they didn't even have to
trade up in order to get him they let
the board come to them
as the as general managers love to say
this time of year and when you do that
and you fill this clear position of need
look they have done the things that they
need to do to protect their young
quarterback you have
the left tackle you have a center in
cory linsley who
has come in as a free agent somebody
that played
in a really good offense for a number of
years played with one of the best
quarterbacks in the league with aaron
rodgers there
in green bay i love that the chargers
have been
able to do what they have done um
over the course of this off season and i
think that they should continue to be an
ascending team with the new head coach
i agree with you and look the way it
fell they got the number two offensive
linemen at spot 13. they weren't going
to get penne sewell without moving up so
it works out well
for them i'm going to say the bears not
because i'm convinced justin fields is
going to be great
but but i like the fact that the
organization
was willing to as a practical matter
make it known
ryan pace is going to be here for at
least a couple of years matt and aggie's
going to be here for at least a couple
years at least i hope that's what the
message is
because you can't put these guys on the
hot seat now you can't fire these guys
after this year if they go 6 and 11.
you have to give this some time let's
see what justin
fields is and i like the resolve i like
the willingness to get back on the horse
four years after
trading up for mitchell trubisky blew up
in their faces they trade up even
farther they give up even more next
year's first round pick
to get justin fields so if it works
they're going to forget about
the fact that they could have had
patrick mahomes that's the goal
because until patrick mahomes retires
you're going to be dogged by that
until you find your own franchise
quarterback i respect them
for number one giving it a try and
number two
hopefully sending the message pace and
naggy are sticking around
bears fans deal with it and just sit
back and enjoy the ride
the one thing that i would counter that
with is that they fired john fox a year
after
trading mitchell they're trading up and
getting mitchell trubisky so
matt maggie maybe you're on the hot seat
but ryan pace man you just may have
bought yourself
another couple years because who knows
how many franchise quarterbacks you get
to draft
before you get it right i'm going to
stick with the
nfc north for my second winner that's
going to be the detroit lions
and i think that they did a great thing
in bringing in pine sol and i think that
he has the potential to be a great
tackle
i mean you see the things that he was
able to do at oregon he's a
nasty guy they're on the offensive line
he brings that tenacity
that's something of course that dan
campbell wants with his kneecap
biters and i think it's gonna be fun to
watch that offensive line work
look the only way for jared goff to
really show his potential
is if he's got a clean pocket most of
the time you know i think we all know
that after seeing his most successful
years
in los angeles there was sean mcvay so
when you've got somebody like taylor
decker at left tackle you've got frank
ragnall
at center now you bring in sewell as the
right tackle you've got three really
good anchor points
to be able to make sure you've got a
clean pocket and with anthony lynn
they should be able to run the ball
better too so at least on first glance i
mean i guess i'm just biased offensive
lineman but
yeah i think that the lions also won
if we are going to declare winners after
one night
sticking with offensive linemen the
vikings being able to trade down from 14
and pass on elijah vera tucker who was
taken
at number 14 by the jets who traded up
they get christian darasaw at 23.
rick spielman the gm of the team said
today they were trying to trade up to
get dara saw they didn't have to
he fell to them and they get two extra
third round picks he thinks
that the third in the fourth round are
the sweet spots of this draft they need
edge rushers so they got a guy they may
have taken at 14
anyway they get two extra third round
picks for their trouble
and and uh the one little ps about the
vikings if justin fields had been there
at 14 that would have been a very
interesting decision for them to make
and they very well may have taken justin
fields which would have
not done much to help them win now but
it
would have created the same reaction
from kirk cousins that we got last year
from aaron rodgers all right who
lost round one miles again with the
caveat we don't really know and
please feel free to play our words back
in a couple of years if we're both alive
then
or if you know we're all alive then
because kyle shanahan says we all could
be dead by sunday
so give me somebody who lost round one
uh you know what i would say the raiders
just because they keep doing this thing
where they tend to reach for guys
and the last time they reached for an ol
it didn't look like it worked in the
first year
but it has over the last couple years
and that's in 2018 when they drafted
colton miller now they just signed him
to a big extension so
that's worked out but if you look over
the last couple years and what they've
done when they've reached for guys right
cleland furl
damon arnett henry ruggs i mean maybe
you want to throw jonathan abram in
there i don't know i think that he
probably would have been a first run
pick anyway maybe maybe not but
those guys that have been picked in the
first round have not necessarily worked
out all that well for them i mean you go
back
to that 2019 draft where that sort of
starts and josh jacobs is the one guy
out of the five where you can say
yes he definitively should have been a
first-round pick and he has produced
like a first-round pick in his first
couple of seasons
if if they really like who they picked
at the right tackle um whose leather
maker
uh gosh i can't believe i don't have
this right in front of me but you know
who i'm talking about they know who we
mean right but if they really like
him yeah if they really like him then
that's what's
blanking and i would have known it too
but because you blanked i blank too so
we're even
alex leatherwood maker jeez
but you know what i'm saying like you
can't keep reaching for guys and missing
guys
if you reach for guys and you're right
then it's fine but if you reach for guys
and you're not right then it's not fine
thank you
so you get fired it's not yeah i get
fired alex leatherwood we'll see what
happens there
for me look this this may sound like
something you've heard before
but i don't like what the 49ers did
giving up three ones and a three to go
get trey lance a guy who didn't play
but one game last year and now they're
acting like he's not going to play this
year because jimmy g is going to play i
still think that's
baloney but when you throw on top of
this indecision
that they seem to welcome and now
they're acting like oh we knew all along
who we wanted i don't know that i buy
that
i like what the falcons did falcons kept
their mouths shut
we don't know who they were gonna take
we don't know who they were thinking and
taking if tray lance and kyle pitts had
been there at four
we don't know which guy they would have
taken and whoever they would have taken
we'd have said fine
because it's not like they were engaging
in this public neuroses as to what do we
do and we're considering this guy we're
considering this guy we're considering
them all
i just think it makes them look
indecisive it makes them look
wishy-washy and when you throw on top of
it
number one that they called the packers
about aaron rodgers
number two for some reason john lynch
felt compelled to admit that when all he
had to say is we don't talk about
players under contract with other teams
that's the coup de gras that's the thing
that makes them seem
like as of wednesday night they were
just like screw it
let's not make a decision let's just
send that pic plus whatever else we have
to send to green bay for aaron rodgers
i mean i understand what you're saying
but i still don't think that you move up
to number three unless you know what
you're doing and i've been saying that
since then why'd they call the packers
for aaron rodgers
he's curious aaron rodgers because it's
aaron rodgers now you don't have to
admit that you did that and i agree with
you they probably shouldn't have
admitted it
but i would still do it okay i mean it's
aaron rodgers there's
a known quantity that you are getting
there with aaron rodgers the reigning
mvp of the league one of the best
players to ever throw a football mike
i'm making the call i i mean
i'm making the call whether or not
that's an excellent point i don't know
and and you know what it underscores the
point that i made when the 49ers made
the trade five weeks ago
because whatever they would have had to
give up on top of the third overall pick
in the draft okay
even if you just get aaron rodgers for
the third overall pick
to get the third overall pick you had to
give up three first round picks and a
third round pick
that is what they traded for trey lance
completely unproven commodity they
traded three ones and a three
to get trey lance and i know there are
people and whenever we went that whole
threat thing oh no they just gave up two
first round no
no to get trey lance what they turned in
was pick 12 this year 2022 first rounder
2023 first rounder and a third rounder
that's what they traded
for lance if they could have traded that
for rogers you strip away
the there's a chance he's not going to
be very good look back to 2018
sam darnold right now fail
josh rosen big fail josh allen success
lamar jackson's success
baker mayfield who the hell knows five
quarterbacks five last night
they're not all five gonna become
franchise quarterbacks so
uh i i can get behind the idea that if
you think there's an opening to get
aaron rodger you give it a try you just
don't say it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports